next 30 minutes or so we hope to share
with you some information about the
hillsdale 1776 curriculum the kind of
k-12 civic education envisioned by
hillsdale college and a brief tour of
how to how the curriculum may be used in
your instruction
we welcome any questions you may have
along the way just send us your
questions in the q a box on your screen
along with your first name and where
you're joining us from we will reserve
time to answer your questions towards
the latter part of this call
without further ado i would like to
introduce dr katie o'toole dr l tool
serves as the assistant provost for k-12
education at hillsdale college she holds
a bachelor's of arts from the university
of dallas in politics and a master's in
phd from claremont graduate university
in political philosophy and american
government her academic interests
include shakespeare
american political thought the
presidency and ancient modern political
theory especially aristotle and thomas
hobbes she was she has taught government
rhetoric literature and moral philosophy
at the k-12 level and was the founding
headmaster of founders classical academy
in leander texas
and dr o'toole is here to introduce to
introduce you to the hillsdale what the
hillsdale 1776 curriculum is how it came
about and its underlying principles dr
o'toole
thank you so much jordan um
and thank you everyone for joining us
um i'm looking at the list of attendees
here and seeing a lot of familiar names
um if you are working in a household
affiliated school right now then i'm
delighted to see you and um hope that
this will be helpful to you
um and to everyone across the country
um what i want to do for those of you
who are not familiar with pistol college
and our work in k-12 education is give
you a brief outline of what we do and
why we do it and then i'll talk to you
about the 1776 curriculum
uh give you a sort of introduction to to
the curriculum the principles behind it
and tell you how it how it all came
about
so first let me tell you about hostile
college um hillsdale college is the 175
plus i think we're 177 years now
um year old institution we're located in
southern michigan
and um
we are a liberal arts college focused on
the classical liberal arts and sciences
with a national
outreach partly as a result of the fact
that we are not just
working to educate the undergraduates
who go to here to college here 1500 of
them but we feel a duty and a desire to
bring the liberal arts education that
these undergraduates receive
to americans across the country
we have online courses
covering lots of aspects of the
curriculum those are available for free
at online.hillsdale.edu
we have a weekly or a monthly speech
digest called in primus
which reaches i believe six million
people now
and
we hold conferences and seminars all
over the country
um
aiming to recover excellence in american
education at the at the college level
about 30 years ago we began working in
k-12 education as well
and our mission there was to bring
the traditional
time-tested study of the liberal arts
and sciences that happens here at
hillsdale college into k-12 schools
in 1990 a private school named hillsdale
academy was founded here on the college
campus hillsdale academy is now 30 plus
years old and it served for many years
as a model school for classical schools
all over the country
the the influence of social academy has
spread far and wide
and
we're very proud of the of the work that
it's done to promote classical education
across the country
about 10 years ago in the year 2010
10 plus years ago
we founded the barney charter school
initiative the barney charter school
initiative is an outreach effort of
hillsdale college through which we
assist local groups of citizens
in establishing a classical school for
their community we provide these schools
with curriculum with teaching advice
with regular professional development
for their teachers
and with guidance on school leadership
and governance as well
the result is we are now working with a
network of classical schools across the
country
who are working from the same curriculum
and the same teaching principles
that that we believe in here at
wholestill college it's a strong network
and it's all working in service of our
mission which is to recover excellence
in american public education through a
recovery of the liberal arts and
education for the hearts and the minds
of students and attention to civic
virtue because after all we are citizens
of this country the united states
that brings us to the 1776 curriculum
um as part of our work with all of these
uh schools that we work with and as part
of our work with professors here at the
college we have over the course of
the last several decades developed a
history curriculum
for teaching kindergarten through 12th
grade students
and up until recently this curriculum
was available to schools working with
hillsdale college it's a scope and
sequence accompanied
by a lot of teaching
advice and communications about
textbooks um
that
in the eyes of hillsdale college's
history department and others we think
have got to be part of a k-12 education
when we
after watching the events of the last
couple of years regarding k-12 education
the pandemic
all kinds of debates about the content
of k-12 education especially when it
comes to american history and civics
and
numerous
parents
becoming increasingly dissatisfied about
what was happening in ordinary american
schools
we thought
we should make these resources available
these resources that have been used in
our schools for so long we should make
them available to everyone in the
country
and that's what this wholesale 1776
curriculum is
we talked to some of the very best
history teachers in our network
and we put their advice about how to
teach american history together with
advice from our history department here
at the college
and we produced to begin with
comprehensive lesson plans primary
source documents and some sample tests
and quizzes
to cover the american founding and the
civil war for students in kindergarten
through 12th grade
uh the the piece of the curriculum
that's been released so far is 2400
pages long
and
it's being used by teachers and parents
all over the country
we've had to date 60 000 people download
it
from every every type of k-12 education
public schools and private schools and
charter schools and homeschooling as
well and that's exactly what we want
the curriculum is free and always will
remain free because our mission is to
see this way of teaching
and this knowledge spread into our
public schools and private schools and
homeschooling families
um across the country
um so the curriculum is
it's a it's a useful
resource we hope it's been
jordan i don't know if uh you know this
but uh dr o'toole's
stream just went down
okay there we go this is me right now
um
if you'd like i'm happy to um
continue myself with with a little bit
or we can wait for drop tool to come
yeah no well uh let's yeah let's keep
going here and and we'll see if uh dr
atul can get back online here um
uh so one of the things that
dr o'toole had mentioned about here is
the role of teachers in creating this
curriculum it's a product of real
instruction taught by real teachers
to real students at actual schools
so one hillsdale affiliate school whose
teachers were instrumental in developing
the curriculum was going view classical
academy in colorado and and uh
as you've heard
here just speak uh dr robert garrow is
the headmaster at golden view classical
academy dr gero earned his bachelor's
degree from the university of colorado
boulder and his phd from the claremont
graduate university in political
philosophy and american government he
teaches government and moral philosophy
at golden view and is the founding
headmaster of the school and i think
this is a good opportunity for him to
outline what civic education the type of
civic education that hillsdalefield
schools
provide to their students and that's now
available through the hillsdale 1776
curriculum dr garrow welcome
jordan thank you um i'm looking forward
to seeing dr o'toole back on uh for
everybody i actually worked for her in
leander and learned everything every
good thing from her um
so at goldenview we teach history and
civics very seriously
um that means that we think it's
important we think it's an important
part of the day
and we begin with
kind of a controversial statement or
controversial belief these days
that patriotism is a virtue
and
on the one hand that seems kind of um
well there's two dangers there one
danger is that you start loving your
country blindly
uh the other one is that you don't love
the good things in the country at all
and if there's
kind of a
general way of things in public
education today my sense is that it's
kind of a cynical attitude of graduates
that america is somehow a bad country
that its history is full of vice more
than virtue and its principles from the
beginning were ill-conceived or um
or full of hypocrite hypocrites
our position is that that's not true we
begin america is good
and you know you're teaching civics to a
12th grader and you're working on the
electoral college you're working on uh
the underpinnings of the declaration of
independence well that begins in
kindergarten with the symbols of america
um bald eagle different kinds of flags
george washington and a variety of
stories around
heroes that kind of shape the sense that
america is a good place in a place that
i'm interested in
if there's anything that really helps
the younger younger students k2 even
k6
is stories of virtue advice and stories
of heroes
i want to talk a little bit about that
just to get a sense of what that might
mean because
if you take george washington for
instance some of the great stories that
you can tell about him as
a
commander in the american revolution or
as a president those things can be a
little bit daunting for a five or six or
seven year old and so they're not
they're not central to their image their
image is a young boy who doesn't lie
and
that is an important part even if even
if those stories are kind of apocryphal
or
not the full picture that's an important
element to say george washington is the
kind of person that i might be like one
day
and that's an important place to begin
um ultimately however the goal of civics
and history education from our
perspective is not um it would be it
would be possible just to come up with a
bunch of george washington's or a bunch
of abraham lincoln's it's students who
can recognize that kind of greatness and
be grateful for it
and the study of the american founding
and study of the civil war in particular
do the do that
principally for washington and lincoln
and others
so stories of virtue advice beginning
with some of the simple acts that that
the great statesmen have done as
children and there's a variety of people
one might pick one of my um
it's a controversial person but but a
really great hero that we teach at
golden view is harriet tubman and we
actually teach harriet tubman in the
context of pe class because
the argument is not just that you can
have morals and you can have a moral
compass and then you can therefore act
on it
she was able
to move hundreds thousands of miles
which is a physical feat and so we ask
students okay if you have a moral
position that you want to be able to
defend can you do it
and that's an argument for why we have
to run a quarter mile every day uh which
they're slowly getting used to um but
it's true that part's true civic
education can wrap up in a lot of
different things that happen at the
school
the other thing i would say is not
is the curriculum what i love about the
1776
uh curriculum is it doesn't shy away
from controversy and doesn't mean to
um you know if we're to pick two of the
harder things to teach from a patriotic
perspective it's going to be
the removal of the indians and slavery
and there's no need to dance around
those subjects one can
teach them directly when they arise in
the curriculum
and honestly
one of the important parts there is in
each of those
circumstances which with each of those
um
injustices there's people on both sides
arguing so it's not just that there's
slave holders there's lots of people
arguing about the justice of this um and
ultimately vindicated in the civil war
um
but but again
instead of taking that you know
something that was unjust like if one
wants to go there with the removal of
indians and ignoring it or or taking it
as the defining feature defining
characteristic of america one can simply
teach it and say these are the people
who are arguing for it these are the
people who are arguing against it this
is what happened and now let's talk
about it that is
the spirit of the 1776 curriculum what
we really like about is about it is um
involving students in a deliberation
about their past
with the premise that america is good
um
so i think that's that's the overall
kind of goal
ultimately
one of the aims is through history
through direct civics education
to have students appreciate
hopefully be grateful for
structure
the structure of the constitution the
structure of our government and being
explicit direct and obvious about all of
these points it becomes really hard in
the later grades to really flesh this
out but that is the key part of our
constitution what makes it lovable
it's not what makes it workable or
useful for purposes but admirable and
worthy of our affection
and deliberating about that in class you
know re-enacting some of the debates
around the constitution
um
that's an incident it's a crucial part
of civics education to be involved in
that kind of thinking
um
i think that's that's really jordan all
i
had to present um and again if there's
questions about how we do it at golden
view or other other approaches as the
webinar goes on i'm happy to address
them
yeah sure
thanks robert i really appreciate it um
do we have dr o'toole back on or okay
all right can you hear me all right hi
hi dr atul yeah all right so dr garrow
just just kind of took us through um
uh you know what civic education looks
like at golden view and through this
curriculum um so i'd like to let you uh
you continue with
yes
yeah
great um
you guys who have been school principals
know that
it's nearly impossible to give a
presentation without some technological
problem happening and it turns out this
is no exception so there we go thanks
for rolling with it guys
um
the the last thing i wanted to say about
the curriculum is that
um there are some principles that it is
built around that i think will be
helpful for those of you who are
considering using it in your classroom
or just thinking about the nature of
history instruction in general
some of the principles include
number one
students can be trusted with the whole
story uh in classical schools we treat
students with respect and we do that by
giving them a curriculum which is full
of the very best that western
civilization human achievement has to
offer we think that
if you can read moby dick in its
entirety you should and that you as a
human being will respond to the
challenge and the joy of doing that more
than you would a summary or a cliff's
notes version of moby dick
that's a literature example but i think
the teaching of history
works a similar way
students can tell when they are being
talked to talk down to
and they can tell when they're being
given a partial or an edited version of
the story and there's really no reason
to do that ever
in in instruction even for very very
young students
um so what the what the 1776 curriculum
does is it gives you the teacher or the
homeschooling parent
tools
so that you can
give students
the full story
this means primary source documents this
means asking questions to help students
discover the theme or discover the
importance of things rather than giving
them
in advance an editorialized or carefully
kind of engineered account of the story
because they will know if you're doing
that
the second principle is that
education should not be politicized
um
that is a
that is a hot topic today and at the
in the media and in um
and in the legislatures state
legislatures and even at the federal
level we're having a discussion right
now about what should students be
learning and how should we be explaining
history to them or science to them
and we think that a lot of that talk is
misguided because it turns out with
history in particular with american
history in particular
um
we have the evidence already
um our country is an old country now but
compared to other countries it's
relatively young
and there is a mountain of evidence
uh to be read for anyone who wishes to
understand its history or the nature of
its founding and so we think give
students that evidence
um trust them with the whole story and
then let them form their political
opinions
as a result of their knowledge of what
actually happened based on those primary
sources
the third principle that i want to
highlight is that
no curriculum can be successful without
a successful teacher
we all went to school we all know
that having the right books in front of
us plato's republic or moby dick or
shakespeare or the world's greatest
you know the world's greatest science
experiment
none of these things can be successful
without
the mediator of the teacher between the
student and the material
and so in classical education at
hillsdale college we pay a lot of
attention to the art of teaching and we
remind ourselves that the great books on
their own cannot teach the average
student instead we have to bring those
books to life that history to life for
the students
and so what you will see if you are a
teacher using this curriculum
is guidance rather than
hillsdale college dictating to you how
it ought to be taught
you'll see ideas and suggestions and
questions to ask rather than a script to
read
you'll see things to focus on
rather than you know a concrete list of
what must be taught
and that's because you the teacher if
you are an excellent teacher of history
a already know a lot about history and b
already know a lot about teaching and
how to be effective for these students
in this setting and it's not the job of
this curriculum or any curriculum to try
to do that essential work for you
we um
we prize teachers and we think that that
profession is an honorable profession
and a profession that the very best
people need to be going into and staying
in and a big um
a big
component of that we think
is understanding the role of the teacher
related to the role of curriculum
the final thing i will say in case it's
um
in case it's not clear already
is that despite what you read in the
news about this curriculum this is not
hillsdale college's counterweight to the
1619 project or the 1619 curriculum
that's a misunderstanding of what we're
trying to do here
there are groups out there that are
producing curriculum that are trying to
achieve a certain end through students
trying to generate students who believe
a particular thing
um and and the who use what they have
learned in school to though to then go
and enact political and social change
this curriculum is not aiming to do that
instead we're aiming to give students
the tools to read everything and
understand everything on their own with
the assistance of talented teachers we
want them to ask the big questions
we want them to
have a rightfully proud um or a rightful
pride in their nation
because america is something to be truly
proud of
but we don't want that pride to
prevent them from asking and
understanding
the true nature of its history
so it's not a it's not a an overly rosy
view or a
view that's seeking to offset
um
you know a more critical account that's
not the right way to understand this
it's a different kind of thing entirely
and i think if you just look at the
curriculum and the way that it
the way that it works and the tools that
it operates you can see that
we truly hope it's helpful for teachers
we are
encouraged by the
the amount of support that we've seen
for it
and one of our goals in the q a is to
help you know how to use it in your
classroom
and so if you have questions about that
then i'd love to love to answer them
thanks jordan that's all i got
great thanks dr o'toole uh and uh yes
please if you have any questions uh put
them into the q a box along with your
first name and where you're joining us
from um lastly on this on this webinar
for our part of it i would like to uh
take uh take a look inside the
curriculum and in particular with an eye
for for what it is for teachers uh it's
uh it's mainly a resource for teachers
rather than something that the students
receive themselves or or anybody else
and so we really want to kind of take a
look at uh what are the features of it
that may be of most greatest interest to
teachers and then how might a teacher
employ that so
we're going to share parts of
a preview of this if you haven't seen it
already and um and i'm just going to
walk walk us through a few points to
this the first one is the matter of
content um and and there there are a
number of things in the introduction to
the to the curriculum um that are going
to be of interest to teachers it's it's
there's a lot of advice in here that
works with the rest of the curriculum so
um
if if we begin if we start off here i
would like to look at the the content
and we and we put this in terms of
engaging in inheritance now
uh what do we mean by this well we think
that one of the main controversies that
uh emerges from around the crick around
teaching american history and civics
is
uh
is that the is that the uh
is that the
way that you do it is is involving what
do you teach in the first place
right um it's it's a matter of of what
what kind of things make the cutter
don't and the reason why we have to do
this because we only have 13 years to
teach students um and so there's no way
to really
you can't do all of it so you have to
cut somewhere what's the principle that
we use to make that decision
we take the approach that the things
that students should study are the
things that are going to mo that have
most significantly shaped their world
that they're going to live in uh
historically there are lots of minutia
and great details and stories that we
love to include but we really ask
ourselves does it rise to the level of
having an outsized impact compared to
other things um and of course this is an
ongoing debate but what we put forward
in the curriculum is is what we think is
is the main way that we go about this
and that's to ignore other ways to do
this including ones to which we're
looking at historical figures based on
the color of their skin for instance um
so that's where we derive how we derive
the content that's in the curriculum um
there's the second thing
something that we're happy about this
for teachers is um a lot of the way that
things are structured nowadays and
teaching resources are
are not very clear um they are kind of
convoluted they use a lot of eduspeak as
it were and uh and and
you know from our own experience and the
experience of our teachers it's it's
it's frustrating and so we try to cut
through that and streamline
what uh what this program entails um and
so we we hope that for teachers it's a
refreshing outline and it's very
user-friendly we wanted it to be uh to
be that above all
so with that i like to turn to the last
thing that we really try to focus on and
and that's the freedom to teach
uh we think that one of the things that
students have
or that teachers have have
had deprived of them
is is the freedom to to teach to uh to
not be weighed down by a lot of other
tasks that they have to do and instead
to recover that love of learning that is
usually the reason why teachers got into
the profession in the first place um and
so
this this has that in mind it wants to
restore the freedom of teachers to teach
and what that means is that as dr
o'toole laid out
this doesn't provide dictates to
teachers it provides guidance certain
parameters and some things that we think
could be good for a teacher to think
about in teaching about american history
and civics that by no means closes off
other options or or uh or unnecessarily
narrows or cramps the style of the the
teacher that the teacher wants to employ
in in their instruction so
uh with that i'd like to
walk us through how we might plan with
the 1776 curriculum um looking at it
okay an example and uh for that like to
go to a middle school uh unit
um
and uh this is it says two of our
initial uh lessons or units and and
they're more forthcoming then eventually
in the early part of 2022 we'll have
enough to canvas all of american history
so um this is how we've laid it out
we've tried to simplify it streamline it
make it easy to read in the first place
so
in addition to a little overview at the
beginning outlining the lessons that are
entailed and pacing guidance for how
many classes a lesson might take
we provide some thoughts on why we're
teaching this unit some main enduring
ideas that we might bring away take away
from it and then some ideas about what
the teacher should consider in the
process
um and this provides kind of a high
level overview of okay get the way of
the land for the teacher before diving
into the actual lesson planning
we also provide texts for how teachers
can use more
or you can learn more and of course this
will take time um but
but you know getting it becoming a great
teacher is a multi-year process as as
the great teachers know and also
hillsdale college online courses free
video courses that we think that are
very helpful to teachers in wrapping
their minds around some of these things
and thinking about the best way to bring
it to the students um so if we dive into
uh one lesson
uh just to highlight a few things uh in
it first of all we suggest that teachers
start by creating a note outline this
goes for any grade level this is k-12 um
but
a a general no outline based on any
student text um that we that we suggest
any primary sources and then teacher
text and in the online online courses
and that becomes kind of the backbone
the spine of of your of our lesson um we
offer some ideas on some uh preliminary
assignments that might go along with it
and then we have the different content
geography in place
uh people this is a people person driven
curriculum it's about real people with
their biographies and the real thoughts
and actions and how those interplay with
each other and results in historical
events right it's not just uh one thing
after another or just a name these are
real people that we want to bring away
for our students and think about why
they're
why they why they're thinking and acting
the way ways they are some terms and
topics to help students navigate um
navigate a lesson in a
period of history primary sources
for students
and some things to know by heart some
things that we think this would be good
for american uh student to to to learn
to memorize to commit to their heart and
to carry with them for the rest of their
lives a brief timeline of major events
that really show how things are related
to each other um and the different
images that we can pull and the internet
is a great resource here we weigh out
here's some images that will go with
this lesson a good quick search engine
engine search we'll bring these up quite
readily then we also have stories that
we have for the american heart uh little
anecdotes and tropes that that that
again students can carry with them and
they can punctuate the lesson and then
you know if we enter into a a a
class and we want to see a lot of
questioning um
you know a lot of not just those
questions of students about the who what
and when and where also the why
questions and the how questions and how
do you know that what does that show us
about this period of history or about
human beings and in human society so um
these are all in there and we think that
you try and you know weave those all
together you don't have to use all of it
it has to be
fine-tuned to your classroom you want
teachers to have autonomy to do that
one of the areas that that we try to uh
provide a little bit more guidance on
are some of those sticky points in
history or civic instruction are there
some things that we oftentimes get wrong
or sometimes there can be a little
thorny to deal with and so we've offered
some thoughts on how to navigate those
and we put them in
the order in which we think that lesson
would naturally proceed and these are
called the keys to the lesson if we get
these things right and carefully think
about them that you're going to end up
with a with a pretty good uh lesson on
the other end and one that's accurate
and true to history um so what does this
look like in the classroom uh we have
this section on pedagogy and taking a
guess through the classroom and what it
looks like and and and what it means is
that the teacher is leading the teacher
is is bringing the students alongside
alongside her and telling a story that's
that's the main thing that we want to do
with this curriculum is tell a story
from uh the the true story of history
and but bring but not just reduce it to
watch but bring students into it by
asking great questions along the way so
they can help tell the story with their
own answers um
these are dynamic lively classes that
that have a momentum to them and a drama
to them and that should be the case for
all of these the study of primary
sources even you're settling in to look
at the real words the real thoughts
unfiltered from the people who lived in
in in the certain events and many times
commit acted in the historical
historical period um so we want all
these things to to bring the history
alive for students uh the last thing
that i'd like to to
preview here
is that we've provided a number of
sample
resources along the way so if i can
quickly scroll through here uh
we can get to a sample assignments a
reading quiz
um
a test that we have laid out sample
study guides for students
and the introduction holds a lot of
information about how best we might
employ this in our classrooms and again
these are not things teachers should
adjust these they should change them so
they fit what they've actually taught in
the classroom and where their students
are at
but we have study guides and we have
tests
sample tests that go along with it and
then
uh a writing assignment that sums up the
entire
unit at the end
here
right here uh you know so uh something
that's that's grade level appropriate
and then we have
four teachers student-ready primary
sources
ones that teachers can readily print off
and of course adjust if need need be but
also that are ready for
ready for teacher for students to pick
up and and to read and we probably a
little bit of background information
some guiding questions and then we've
laid it out so it's double spaced plenty
of room for students to annotate and a
right-hand margin that for notes and
questions so um you know i think that
that what we what we get from this is is
a is a different kind of different way
of approaching this one that is a bit of
a throwback to an older to uh to what
history used to be but the same time i
think some improvements that our schools
have made in this instruction so um i
just like to to leave off with that and
that gives you a good sense and a lot
more information is in the introductory
introduction to the curriculum about how
to best use this in your classrooms
so
uh with that i would like to reserve the
remaining time here um to to address any
questions
uh uh we might have out there so
um the the first question and i'll pose
this to dr o'toole who has been header
uh header had concentrated on this over
the last year or so um but you know as a
first-time homeschool mom uh from susan
uh can they do this can a home school
mom do this and and
um and then dr o'toole maybe i can
answer one of our follow-up questions
which is how can i best prepare
yeah great
um well thank you for that question we
get we get that question all the time
and i think that's because parents uh
one of the good things about kovid one
of the few good things about covid was
parents got to see what was really
happening
in their children's classrooms because
the work was coming home sometimes the
zoom meetings were happening in the
dining room and a lot of parents thought
wait a minute i this is not what i was
expecting i was expecting something a
lot better than this
um and so a lot of them took matters
into their own hands got used to doing
that and suddenly realized wait a minute
i might be able to do this better at
home then
then um
you know would be done if i was sending
my children to school
and here here at the college we get
questions almost weekly from
parents who want to use hillstone
college's k-12 curriculum at home
and we are working hard on providing a
curriculum for homeschooling families
it's a big project and it'll be a while
before it comes out but in the meantime
i think the 1776 curriculum is a great
place to start
what it will provide you is kind of an
idea about how to teach students at
different grade levels so if you have a
kindergartener
it will be refreshing to you to know
what kindergartners in other hillsdale
schools classical schools across the
country are doing and what kind of
things they're capable of
you as the parent know your child better
than anyone and so you will you will
have an idea about how to go about it in
your own home but the curriculum can
give you an idea about things to read
online courses hillsdale college offers
a lot of online courses related to
american history and civics and
economics too that will be helpful for
deepening your own understanding
and i think this is a great way to go
about it
if you are looking for more guidance
about homeschooling it's coming soon ish
but in the meantime we'd love to point
you in the right direction
for literacy and for mathematics and for
some other things too you can just email
k12 hillsdale.edu
yeah and susan i think that
one thing to to keep in mind and this
goes for all teachers uh man
homeschooling parents
is it's just start somewhere um you know
something is better than nothing and and
uh if the first first way that we use
this is to supplement things that we're
already doing that's great right that's
a starting point and and um you know
teachers know that you know you can't go
out there every single day and hit a
grand slam um in your first year of
teaching something or else you're going
to be worn out very quickly and it's not
going to be very good and so you know
going out there and saying okay i'm
going to just follow what i'm learning
here um and go within pulling the things
that i can as for as much time as i have
for it um that that's fine and i think
the the main thing is to for all
teachers to discover that love of their
content for themselves and that will
drive a lot of of what you of what you
share with your teacher with your
students and what that content looks
like and um i think that if if we
approach it in that way um and just
start pulling some of the things in and
as dr o'toole mentioned uh reading some
of the teacher resources there there or
watching or listening to the online
courses that we've highlighted from
hillsdale college uh then that's that's
going to get you pretty far um and
there's a lot there but the idea is to
let's put it all on the table for
teachers to use
um a great question another question uh
from dean is asking if this is a
stand-alone curriculum and i i'm
guessing that means is this the only
curriculum that hillsdale offers and
i'll let dr o'toole address that i think
she kind of addressed it in passing but
maybe she can speak to a little bit more
probably as i was cutting out hi dean
dean bowen is from waterbrook christian
academy and he sent us a very nice note
the other day um we're fans dean
um
so the question is what is the
relationship of this to the to the rest
of the curriculum is that correct
yeah yeah is this a stand-alone thing or
are there other things here it stands
alone um but it's created from the k-12
program guide which is hillsdale
college's
scope and sequence curriculum
for its k-12 schools
um
the program guide is the product of many
decades of work on the part of great
teachers and professors here at the
college and we created the 1776
curriculum by taking
the relevant portions of the program
guide
from k-12 for
american history civics
in eighth grade and
government in the high school we took
them out and we did the prep
that a teacher would do if the teacher
were teaching that curriculum so it's
the same scope and sequence but with
resources deepened
and this is the kind of project gosh if
we go crazy we could do this for every
subject i mean we could do this for
science we could do this for literature
we've got talented teachers all over the
country who are doing this kind of work
and by showing you the curriculum like
this you can see what's happening in
hostile schools and what's possible in
schools all over the country
so very closely related um they match in
scope and sequence the 1776 curriculum
was just
deeper than the
program guide
i should say um jordan the k-12 program
guide
is a um
it's a it's available to schools across
the country
uh via free license
we have schools all over the place apply
to use this curriculum
and we we try to make it available to as
many people as we can there's an
application process involved just to
ensure that the school is going to use
it in accordance with the mission
um
but um it's a it's a valuable resource i
think for schools that are looking to
make sure that
their teaching of an individual subject
is excellent and are also looking to
make sure that their vertical alignment
if they're a k-12 school or a k-e school
their vertical alignment is where it
ought to be
so if you're interested in information
about the whole curriculum
you can
email k12 hillsdale.edu and we can talk
to you about the free licensing program
great uh thanks and we have time for one
last question this is from lou in rhode
island i'll pose this one to dr garrow
um
uh just just very quick response from dr
garrow i i know some people thinking the
phoning is obsolete does the curriculum
address the issue of how and why
students take the past seriously
okay yeah great question um
it's a it is a hard question i think
the main thing the main kind of approach
that a teacher takes to combat that is
just simply take the founding seriously
from the beginning
if you engage on the questions of for
instance why does the constitution allow
for the slave trade to continue for a
limited time
um you have to engage the arguments and
you have to put yourself in the position
of the people who had to make these
decisions with real alternatives on the
table
um
so just simply going going forward and
taking it seriously is the first kind of
lesson on its own
about the founding or about any kind in
the past um it's also i find that that's
a fun question to just engage students
with with the question you know at what
point does the history become
unimportant to you
and
typically
you know they they have kind of a
general sense that there's a the past is
kind of obsolete but they don't know
when they don't know how and they can't
say like oh it was in 1945 or it was in
you know
two generations ago and pushing them on
that question i think gets them to see
that
if the argument's good the argument's
good it doesn't matter when it was made
um
and that in general that can that brings
most students around my my experience
katie did you have anything you'd like
to
address about that as well
no i think that's exactly right and hi
lou i'm glad you're here
um
yeah it's i think i think you're right
like students kind of naturally feel
like oh that was very old and that was a
long time ago and
what does it have to say today
but if you have a
fabulous storyteller who's bringing
these things to life that can kind of
um
indirectly show students that we can
learn from history history matters
um
you know if you read this is one of my
favorite things about teaching and
reading aristotle you think you know
aristotle and ancient greece with his
toga i know it was so many thousands of
years ago but when you read what he's
writing about
and what he's concerned with like i'm
concerned with that stuff too as is
every student i've ever taught like what
does it mean to be happy what does it
mean to be good how should i think about
money how should i think about pleasure
how should i think about honor and so if
you can just sort of show they're
worried about the same stuff that we're
worried about and that's the stuff that
really matters
and the fact that they were wearing a
toga while they were worrying about it
doesn't really make a difference there's
something more fundamental here um so we
talk about that approach in the
curriculum and i think we we see that
approach in some of our best some of our
best schools
great well um
uh
the the curriculum is available for free
at k12.hillsdale.edu
um on behalf of dr o'toole dr garrow at
the hillsdale k-12 education office and
the teachers in our two dozen affiliate
schools i'd like to thank you for
joining this conversation
we welcome any feedback you may have on
the curriculum and hope that you'll find
the hillsdale 1776 curriculum helpful in
teaching about america thank you for
your